okay
there we go here we go
ow this is that time of year where you
shock everything metal that you touch in
here all right what's up mkbhd here just
wanted to talk
just me and you for a real quick minute
what's up so there's a bunch of things
that have been evolving in the
background that you haven't seen that
have been completed right around now so
i wanted to share them with you a lot of
these things when they're an
announcement they end up as a tweet so
if you're not following me on twitter
already
a lot of these things end up there first
but here we are this kind of feels like
a little new year's update video
basically because we always have we know
the second half of the year in this tech
world is
product focused there's so many things
that come out i mean you guys know about
tectober but we're always so in the
thick of it about covering and sharing
all this new stuff that's coming out and
figuring out if it's any good and then
we get to january
and then we get ces and then there's
kind of like a little bit of a little
bit of a chill period now there are
still some products here and there but
this is definitely uh january and now
february is more of a chance to sort of
refresh things a little bit and that's
actually something i enjoy like just as
much as the rest of the videos because
if you don't change things up a little
bit if you don't stay on your toes a
little you might find yourself in cruise
control so we'll be doing exactly that
you guys have seen the new intro also
new channel banner for 2022 fresh new
graphics absolute fire just freshening
things up you know i'll always have a
place in my heart for all of the
previous years graphics and and banners
but if we're not moving forward we're
standing still so we're getting better
the studio channel is going strong and
we're trying all kinds of new things
over there behind the scenes looks
tutorials mini reviews even shorts and
now also that channel has a new banner
too by the way so if you aren't
subscribed to the studio you're missing
out there's so much good stuff but
speaking of new there's some even bigger
new stuff that i lowkey wanted to i kind
of want to launch everything like right
around new year's but some of it took a
little longer because we wanted to get
it just right and so we've gotten to
that point now so it's february 1st as i
record this but there's some good stuff
so number one new channel i have
officially launched an mkbhd
shorts channel for the hashtag shorts
link is below there's already two shorts
there as of right now with many more to
come and so now normally launching a new
channel i'd be like alright go over
there right now and subscribe but i'm
not gonna say that i'm not gonna do that
only go over there to that link to that
shorts channel if you really
want to see i really like
tic tocs and shorts and that's probably
like sacrilegious to say in the
cinematography communities and you know
i although 30fps for life so maybe i'm
not in all of those communities but
there's just something different it's
obviously a very different format but
it's a different challenge to package
information in that way and to make a
really good
short like i i can make a video an mkbhd
video but the new challenge of making a
good what is an mkbhd short that's
actually really fun for me so it's still
tech related it's still high quality but
i wanted to give you the modularity
basically to be able to subscribe also
to shorts if you want to or not
subscribe if you don't want to see them
so instead of putting them all in one
place you can decide if you're
interested in shorts and subscribe there
if you want i'm not ruling out the
possibility of posting occasional shorts
on this channel i haven't done it yet
but you know i might as well it's fun to
play with but that's the idea is to give
you that ability to subscribe to exactly
what you want to like that's why we have
a separate channel for the waveform
podcast and a separate channel for the
studio
now if you want mkbhd shorts you know
exactly where to go plus it's got a
pretty sweet new banner too so why not
and then another brand new thing brand
new
website
oh yeah mkbhd.com used to be uh pretty
embarrassing if i'm being honest
probably the only way you can actually
see what it used to be is if you're on
like a archive or something like that
but the new site is everything i wanted
we took the extra time and now mkbhd.com
is a beautiful
functional
secure
dope site as a hub for all things here
it is mobile friendly of course as you'd
expect and as a bonus we created two
entirely unique websites that you can
flip between with the flick of a switch
because there is a dark mode toggle so
there's a dark mode version of the
entire website and that site of course
is where you'll find the new merch and
we've refreshed the entire mkbhd merch
store that's where you'll find all this
stuff and by the way we're graduating
from more than just apparel so we've got
the whole checkout process streamlined
it's entirely contained on mkbhd.com
but it's going to be more than just like
clothes stuff so we still got the soft
shirts and the long sleeves and the
hoodie and the windbreaker that's all
great also now we've got hats we've got
five panel hats and beanies for the
winter months and then some actual
products so the desk matt mousepad we've
been teasing a few times is actually
incredible i love this thing and then
there's also a matte black woodwick
candle that is a new studio scent i
don't know if you've ever made your own
candle before but the process for making
your own candle is quite fascinating and
you end up obviously designing the
outside but also
it smells like a studio full of
new gadgets and that's kind of awesome
that we actually managed to make that
happen so we have a candle so there's
that and there's even more coming soon
i'll keep you guys posted on when the
new stuff drops i'll tweet that of
course too but i think this is the best
drop we've ever had and it's the most
complete store we've ever offered and it
is the best way to support the channel
directly i think probably one of the
biggest misconceptions about running a
channel in general is that it's easy
and it you know it can still be easy to
make super simple basic videos it
started off easy but
if you have ambitions to do better
things or to do more
which many do
it's not easy and that's exactly why
we're hiring so that's sort of the last
mini announcement is that i've updated
the application that's on the site to
join the team at the studio that's
response it's a slowly growing creative
team but it's responsible for all of the
stuff that you see on all these channels
and on the site and in the store and on
the separate projects we're also working
on that you'll see coming soon
that is happening so a couple of
positions that i know i'm definitely
looking for right now are an assistant
waveform producer for the podcast um ad
sales
and an editor
so after 13 years of editing all these
videos you know maybe there's some room
for growth there too but basically
anytime there's updates to that for what
positions i'm hiring for at the studio
you can always just click the apply link
and you can see that right there and if
you ever want to apply that'll always be
there and then last thing i'm going to
be doing i'm going to be trying some
live stuff some like live chats directly
with you guys maybe q a type stuff um
and i'm running it as a trial with
people who are members of this channel
so you've had that like join button down
below and many people have generously
been
members of the channel supporting and
all they've really gotten is like a
little badge next to their name i
appreciate y'all
but we're gonna have uh yeah i'm gonna
do some members live streams and just do
some chats and q and a's and games and
stuff like that and see what that's
about on this channel as well so
while we're at announcements just one
more quick one for you um and that's
that's pretty much gonna do it new
graphics new channels
new website new dark mode theme
new merch
new people
it's all coming together i love this
time of year that's been it
back to your regular schedule
programming see you later peace